fishes in the Seas if you think videos
of pets is as good as it gets this
segment is from you we hope your furry
dreams come true it's time to celebrate
Briggs animal friends
[Music]
welcome back to Greg's animal friends
the segment where each guest is kindly
asked to share a phenomenal video of an
awe-inspiring creature cat you go first
I don't know about awe-inspiring but
there's a cute little puppy that look at
him so he's playing with this pig thing
and look at him he's so cute but look
he's not like doing well you know what I
mean like whoa there he goes
oh look so then he moves on he moves on
then we can all learn from that if it's
not working just move on to something
else
that is true
piercings might be growing into some
kind of fat chick oh boom look and he's
like you know what I don't need you I
can be by myself and do just fine yeah
wow he's dizzy very very confused look
at that what kind of owner would give a
puppy a big fat toy like that if he
wasn't training him to hate fat people
what about you pig Emily I have two for
the price of one two animals take a look
and my two it's a dog and a dog dressed
up as a spider oh look how funny this is
this is a little tiny like Gus type dog
yes and he's totally terrorizing a
Rottweiler because he's dressed up as a
I have that spider costume adorable and
it just goes to show that everyone is
scared of spiders yes
it's not funny I have that spider
costume I put it on jeans it was really
tough
yeah you know I guess I guess you know
this just it's like you can maybe little
dogs should have little outfits that
they can wear see that's all fun till
the finally the rot gets stressed out
and does one bite oh yes exactly I
should dress like that on Sixth Avenue
and then everyone will leave me alone I
don't think that will happen yes I don't
think that'll happen we'll miss you yes
Kyle where what is your pet video well
mine is um you know we talked about the
women's soccer team this is the most
exciting thing that's ever happened at a
soccer game and a raccoon
uh fell into the Press Box
and they're chasing it around and then
they're chasing the raccoon and they're
holding it up with this broom trying to
fight it off and I think it ends up
falling into the crowd below
so soccer's finally fun and exciting
thanks to these raccoons
a little guy yeah we've done we've done
a lot a fair share of soccer bashing and
I want to reach out to the audience we
don't really hate hate soccer we just
loathe it
we don't hate it though raccoons are a
very underrated animal I believe you
know people don't like them because
they're they travel in packs and they
have beady eyes and they steal from you
you know as a matter of fact maybe I do
hate them
I hate raccoons if you want a trash can
you're not a fan of a raccoon yes and I
do like trash cans I'm a huge trash can
big Oscar the Grouch guy yeah exactly
what about you I I bet I have a feeling
these are your animals yeah these are
mine uh so the beginning of Summer I
bought a bag full of uh Pac-Man frogs
which are like the size of a nickel when
you get them and now they're all the
size of my hand wow these giant
monsters and then I got some crazy
colors that came out that's a albino
pixel Pac-Man frog and we had a video of
it eating a mouse for you but the people
got too scared of it that one's actually
translucent which is kind of gross
because you can see all his organs
moving when he eats and stuff but
they're super aggressive they make this
crazy sound that my daughter makes
because they like to chew on your hands
and stuff anything in front of their
mouth they'll eat it so they're really
gluttonous like they would love Cinnabon
but and then when they don't like you
they make this high pitch like and my
daughter thinks it's the greatest thing
in the world and I'll just hear that
yeah like stop the Frog
do they smell no they don't smell are
they affectionate do they ever like to
come one come up to you and say oh Tyrus
like a little puppy some do the frogs
not so much although the really big one
likes to to like sit in your hands and
just stare at you like having a staring
it's a good way to see where your head's
at if you get a staring contest with the
Frog but most of the time they try to
eat anything anything that gets in their
mouth that's why it's tough to breed
them because they're not afraid to go
cannibal so oh they eat their sex party
well the men are smart they're bigger
and then once she lays the eggs they eat
her and who knew
how Carefree his life was after that
because then
no one there's no back talking or
nagging the eggs hatch he raise them
under his moral code they do things that
he wants to do and they're all happy and
fun so I mean don't not Mother Nature
until you know sometimes it works
they've been around for a lot longer
than we have so who knew all we had to
do was eat our wives after they have our
children
yeah you'd have no fights over schooling
no nothing oh no homeschooling bedtime
it's like can't talk to Mom I ate her
yeah
and then you always get the do you want
to end up like Mom yeah
thanksgiving's right around the corner
get those grades up speaking of oh up
next Cookie Monster would be jealous
over what this study can tell us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else